Papst franziskus nämlich der hat jetzt
öffentlich gestanden dass er Pornos
konsumiert und dabei ist er nicht
alleine nicht er hat gestanden
Entschuldigung sondern er spricht auch
öffentlich über den Pornokonsum von
Priestern und Nonnen und er sagt ja klar
auch sie schauen Pornos Kirchen
Oberhäupter ja was für eine Sünde eine
Sünde die vielen Leuten leihen Priestern
und Ordensschwestern auferlegt sagt der
Papst und gleichzeitig warnt er Pornos
Last bitte die Finger davon
[Musik]
Halleluja was für eine Offenbarung
Papst franziskus er ist der coolste und
lockerste Papst seit tja und 2000 Jahren
unser populärer Pontifex ist pro LGBT
und zweifelte zumindest anfänglich an
der Sinnhaftigkeit des Zölibats jetzt
lüftet das Kirchenoberhaupt ein neues
und intimes Geheimnis bei einem Treffen
mit Priestern in Rom spricht der Papst
tatsächlich über Pornografie Zitat das
ist eine Sünde die vielen Leuten leihen
Priestern und Ordensschwestern auferlegt
was
[Musik]
Priester und Nonnen gucken auch Pornos
heiligs Blechle ein globales Stoßgebet
richtet sich gern Himmel apropos
Stoßgebet
Missionarsstellung
Orgelpfeifen da geht jetzt ganz viel
Kopfkino
ja madonna hat es schon 1989 gewusst
like a prayer es läuft was unter den
langen Robben und Kutten ein jeder frönt
der Fleisch ist Lust und das ist gut so
aber Achtung Papst franziskus hat seine
Brüder und Schwestern beim Geständnis
auch gewarnt seit vorsichtig mit
Pornografie so tritt der Teufel ein
[Musik]